each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
right so thanks everybody for coming
this is a talk from asha been a yeah and
the speaker is going to be good Cilic
allah hopefully that's all right there
from Ryerson University and they're
going to be giving a talk on
confirmation bias and how it affects
software engineering let me just tell
you a little bit about goo so she holds
a PhD and Master of Science degrees in
computer science that Anna BS in
mechanical engineering from bogazici
bazi tea University oh yes she's also
awesome there's a lot of rich people
it's awesome used to be a research and
development engineer at a lot ago
carrier and she later was a researcher
in the software research lab at the
computer engineering department of
bogazici university what I'll get it
right today she's fairly a postdoc
fellow at the data science laboratory at
Rice University and she studies Merkel
software engineering software
measurement and cognitive aspects in
software engineering software keysight
prediction mining data repositories and
machine learning so what the heck i give
you you thank you thank you
hello first of all we'd like to thank
you for hosting us and it's a great
pleasure to be with you all guys so
today's talk is going to be about as
Andrew mentioned confirmation bias as a
human aspect and software engineering
but first of all I'd like to talk about
a little bit who we are where we came
from and how our research originated and
what is our present research what is our
vision in research so let me give you a
brief information about our data science
lab our lab mainly builds intelligent
models to solve problems in software
engineering domain in a while a lot of
mental issues and in biology and while
doing that we use some this we use some
theories from disciplines such as
machine learning artificial intelligence
statistics psychology cognitive
psychology and so on and here's our
current staff and it causes off three
faculty members from three different
departments which are industrial
engineering computer science and
information systems and a postdoctoral
research fellow that's me and three PhD
students for ms students and we are
trying we are planning to expand our
staff by including eight six or more
graduate students so I guess some of you
might know our alumni and PhD alumni I
think these people are familiar to
Microsoft Research I share was an intern
at Microsoft Cambridge two years ago I
think it was in 2010 and last time we're
a problem was an intern at Microsoft
Redmond here and Barack is from
University of all the insolent he's a
researcher there and he's been doing
collaborative research with you about
mostly intestine development and all the
12 years in it our work originates
back to 12 years before and it was
originated in Istanbul Turkey by
Professor aishah banner and our goal is
to collaborate with industry as much as
we can because it's very important for
us to solve real-life problems and so we
have been collaborating with industry
forever long time and in terms of that
are sharing and sometimes funding and
sometimes in terms of joint publications
and these are our current collaborations
and projects we have we have been
collaborating with IBM in Canada IBM
Toronto software laboratories and mostly
with the development team of db2 for
almost two or three years and we are
also collaborating with CSM months in a
hospital so what are our research areas
will we have faculty members and they
have their specific research areas other
than professor banner dr. oz gatorade
can ever is specialized in organization
and presentation of information and dr.
al Amiri is specializing
privacy-preserving data mining and cloud
and professor banner tries to solve
problems and software engineering
domains and in other domains and
especially in problems industry by
building intelligent Oracle's so
regarding the research of Professor
banner as I said before it goes back to
about 12 years and when software lab was
founded it started to do research at the
intersection of a and software
engineering so we started to the soul
problems in software engineering domain
using some disciplines methods and
techniques from artificial intelligence
and our goal was to enhance the
performance of the vector addiction
models so why do we use the fact
prediction models in our laps we usually
use it for the effective allocation of
resources before the testing sort for
the testing phase so that
are we can guide the testers protesting
project managers which parts of the
software needs to be test first or
priority to which parts of software
priority should be given so that we can
catch more bugs in less time and losing
less money so first of all we try to
conversion already existing algorithms
and try to find out what is the outcome
and of course at the same time there
were other researchers who are working
in similar subjects with us and they got
some they obtained some very significant
results in this field in terms of the
player performance of their predictors
so first of all we try to combination
logarithms then we wanted to find out
whether it is the problem is in data
science so that is it possible that by
increasing the data data size we can
increase the performance of our
predictors and we found that by doing
matters such as under sampling even with
small data we can obtain the same
results that we obtained with more data
so this means that the problem is
probably it's very highly likely that
the problem is not in data size and it's
a good thing because it's not easy to
obtain data in software engineering
field and most of it is noisy so we
sometimes having detected the noise that
we have to get rid of that part and what
is left with us is something very small
so it's a good sign for us and also
there is a data content first of all we
also try new algorithms we new methods
and we obtain some improvement in the
performance and later parallel with
other researchers and some of you are
here in this room we tried the file
depends in the sea grabs feta corn
called metrics sure metrics and also the
design matrix which are which have been
extracted from the requirements
documents
and these were mainly related to the
product itself software code and the
software processes but also there is
another thing our region s human aspects
need to be integrated into prediction
models in order to increase the
performance of the predictors because
software is being designed developed and
tested by people and so in the
literature they're also very see there
are also some techniques methods which
have been proposed and which gives
significant results like organizational
metrics by mega pan or social
interactions by bird mentally and
developer experience by vereker and so
on and so we told that we should go
deeper in people said and that is what
our current research is about and we're
interested mainly in the thought process
of people and also we had another region
of us this as well as concentrating of
the human himself we also think that to
support is very important so because we
just want to solve the problems in real
life and so we developed a tool in our
laboratory and our laboratories name was
previously soft lab in Istanbul and it
parses the code and it's extract some
metrics and predicts the defective parts
of the software by employing and it says
some conventional and also new methods
in AI and machine learning and it is an
open source code and based on this
previous tool pressed it was pressed we
also we have been currently developing
another software which is much more
extensive large scale and it is a
web-based software and it consists of
certain modules and modules include
metric extraction production of the
defective parts of the software afford
cost estimation and reliability predator
release management reliability
prediction of the software
and also there is the people module so
that for which can be used also by the
HR people for the recruitment of the
personal performance evaluation of the
personal and also so we said that are we
have now currently focused on two things
development of add support to which
helps the practitioners and also human
aspects in the fat prediction models and
we want to model human aspects and dream
up here on aspects in two ways people as
part of a team and people as individuals
so as people as part of the team what we
look for is a researcher in our lab he's
going to graduate from his PA he's going
to graduate in from his PhD suit is
mining issue management systems and is
trying to find out who should fix which
back so that the tasks can be allocated
based on the guidance which is given by
his models now I'm going to talk about
confirmation bias which is the main
subject of the stock will why human
aspects of software engineering our goal
is to enhance decision making under
uncertainty to guide managers to solve
some critical problems in any case of
the software development lifecycle and
these questions can be various during
the daily they come up during the daily
software engineering activities and this
can be something like which parts of
software should be prioritized for
testing who should test develop the most
critical parts of software who should
fix the bugs in the most problematic
parts of software who should or should
not develop maintain the same source
files at the same the same source files
or who should be higher as a developer
or who should fits the profile of a
tester analyst or designer most so these
are some of the questions and the list
of questions can be extended for and we
want to find out the answer so we want
to guide the managers and the
professionals in answering the
such questions so people's thought
processes have a significant impact I
mean how we solve problems the way we
think the way we reason has some has in
fact in software itself in the qualities
of the software because software is test
designed tested develop and manage by
people and while solving problems in
daily life rather than mathematics or
logics we use some heuristics shortcuts
because time is limited and these horse
dicks are not a hundred percent correct
there if you are lucky 90 or 95 percent
correct maybe and one day and when they
fail to produce a correct judgment this
may result in a cognitive bias so
cognitive wise the deviation of the
human mind from mathematics and logic
and there are some common cognitive bias
types and there are many and when you
look at Wikipedia you can see hundreds
of different types of cognitive bias and
some of the cognitive bias might be
related with each other each other and
so there is a confirmation bias there is
anchoring and adjustment available TR
representativeness well so we firstly
focused on confirmation bias and why
confirmation bias so first of all to
answer this question what is
confirmation bias well given some
hypotheses we have the tendency to seek
evidence to verify those hypotheses
rather than refuting them we do not have
the tendency to fight how find high
point reasons or evidence which can
refute our hypothesis this is a tendency
of human beings in real life and it has
some good it has some advantages but on
the other hand it may also have some
disadvantages so in some way we should
help as well as a very frank mechanism
in somewhere we show you should will
have also refuting mechanism going all
together so my confirmation bias well
indeed it all started when I read the
article by Stacy I'm a chameleon
Communications it's an old article it
was published in 1994 1995 but was an
interesting one it was about it was a
kind of a brainstorming it was it didn't
present an empirical results but wasn't
talking about these biases like
representativeness availability and
confirmation bias and how my T's show up
in Dale's or engineering activities and
how might they affect the quality of the
software so then we found I came up with
work I came across with work of teasley
and their head they their empirical
results showed that the testers have
some tendency to the positive tests
rather than preferring negative tests so
as a result we wanted to search more
about the confirmation bias and we found
that the term confirmation bias was used
by wisdom in cognitive psychology
literature almost 60 years ago and he
has some famous test psychological
experiment Surrey to show the existence
of confirmation bias among people so and
over the 60 years and vision also admits
that he's surprised that over 60 years
variations of these psychological
experiments have been designed and / for
conducted on people as well as the
replications of the original ones and so
there are some publications still going
on in this pro in the subject in
cognitive psychology and it wasn't
expected to be that popular so we had so
we had some empirical evidence showing
existence of confirmation bias among
software people and also we have some
grounded work which range across the
whole 60 years and it was something and
we also have been collaborating with
professors from the Department of
Psychology and we came within we perform
some grade-a brainstorming and during
our collaborations they consulted us and
we came up with some methodologies to
quantify confirmation bias
by taking their consultant they by
consulting them and performing
brainstorming meetings and so on so due
to confirmation bias the only
opportunity perform going to test for
instance if you take developers let make
their program work rather than to break
their code we don't say that they their
ultimate goal should be to break their
code of course we need some scenarios
for verification purposes but we mustn't
neglect the night has scenarios which
have the probability to fail our code so
that the facts are not overlooked for
the testing place so we say that during
low levels of software testing we must
employ a strategy within which includes
adequate attempts to fail the code to
reduce software defect density so we
wanted to make some empirical research
we wanted to find some answers to
questions such as how does confirmation
bias excuse me sir
yeah well well the only testing we want
the goal is to make to make sure whether
that program work that it whether that
module that part of the software works
correctly before we can integrate all of
them together so but when it is
especially when it is our own code
without knowing the unconsciously we
just want to make it work so and during
infinite number of scenarios indeed and
it's we cannot do exhaustive testing but
most of the time we are stuck with the
older on the overall space of possible
testing us we are Muslims stuck with the
ones which make our program work and
most of the time do it unconsciously so
so we wanted to find out what is the
effect of confirmation bias on software
defect density and and how can we use
this information are there any ways
perhaps to circumvent confirmation bias
and this is the question that whose
answer we are still seeking for it's
very important but first of all we had
to quantify in some terms confirmation
bias because we were working with matter
methodologies like machine learning
algorithms AI Metis I mean we are using
robust neighbors networks nowadays
rather than the sophisticated ones just
because there's too much noise in our
data but so at the end we had some we
needed some numbers and so this was our
first challenge in our research and and
the question was how can we identify the
measures of confirmation bias in
relation to software development process
this was the prerequisite research
question that we have to answer before
answering the other questions in our
minds so given this challenge as a part
of our brainstorming collaborations with
the psychologists we came up with a
methodology that is a literal which is
an iterative process and so we initially
came up with a confirmation bias test we
prepare the confirmation bias test and
it was almost like a compilation of the
experiments in psychology and which able
to show the existence of confirmation
bias Emma and as well as this the
formation of confirmation bias metrics
set so we wanted to form from the
outcomes of these confirmation bias
tests which are conducted administered
to the software engineers some matrix
and our test which we administered first
of all we administered this test
initially tried pilot group and
afterwards we went on to the field and
conducted did to various software
professions in various industries from
different domains and it consists of two
parts what personal part was interacted
test and it was based on way since rule
discovery task which I'm going to talk
about soon and way since we didn't test
the written test and it was based on
wasted selection task and I'm also going
to talk about so the abstract the
written test was a congressional pen and
paper test and interactive test was 121
so there was a tester and there was a
subject and subject was giving given
some feedback by the tester throughout
the whole test protocol and so we were
also recording to doing some sounds
recording in order to find out the way
that he thinks and at the same time the
subject was writing down what he affects
how he solves the problem so that we
just wanted to find out
patterns of problem showing that he or
she follows to find out to find out a
solution during the test and so and let
me come to the written test written test
consists of the questions of abstract
and chaotic questions and i'll talk
about them more and as i think is going
to be much clearer when I talk about
waste and selection a task so when we
answer abstract questions logical
reasoning is required without logical
reasoning it's not all it's almost
impossible to answer them correctly but
sometimes we are in real life also
without logical reasoning and this is
what we do most of the time you use our
daily life experience and some
mechanisms like memory clinic to answer
questions so teams and the team of the
question if it is something close to
real life setting or if it is something
close to that we are familiar with it
makes it much easier to answer it under
sense because we can understand it much
easier so we do not need some type of an
abstraction to solve it so there is also
so we prepare chaotic questions and also
we wanted to find out what if the team
of the questions are from the software
development and testing domain so here
is Wizards rule discovery task and I
took this from his original paper which
was published in nineteen sixty I guess
so we also connected the similar
experiment to software that will
approach from various of various
companies and so subject is initially
given three numbers
which conform to a simple rule it's a
very simple rule and the goal is to find
this rule and this rule is only known by
the tester I mean who con who
administers the test to the subject and
so the protocol is something like that
you write down trip three numbers having
seen these numbers and you write down
reasons for choice why you chose them
what is the specific thing about these
three numbers and then the tester gives
feedback just by looking at three
numbers whether those three numbers
conform to the rule that he has in his
mind that the rule that needs needs to
be discovered by the subject and he said
he just says it conforms to the room the
number three numbers that you gave
conformed to the room or it does not and
if this may go on like this the subject
making more numbers together with
reasons for choice and they write down
their reasons for choice and at the same
time they meeting loud so we are
recording the and we just and the
subject is given frequently feedback
four-inch instance of three numbers that
he gives and at the end when he is sure
about what the rule is he alone is he uh
no so set and if the rule is correct
then we are done so the test will
complete that is completed but if it is
incorrect the same protocol may go on I
mean the subject can give three numbers
and reasons for choice and expecting
feedback and that's receiving feedback
from the tester whether those three
numbers conforms to the rule and it may
go on however long the subject wants and
of course during the protocol it is also
possible to terminate and the subject
made you up to test you can say I you up
so is that a volunteer we can try it do
we have
thank you is there anyone who wants to
try it so initially we have two numbers
three numbers
would you like to give three numbers
yeah the this is a starting point and
probably based on this these three
numbers you have some ideas about what
yeah you will give some example sent
what first of all you need to give an
example I mean three numbers no it
doesn't have to follow it doesn't have
to be related any three numbers that
comes to your mind which is possibly
something related with the hypothesis
that you have in your mind
so why did you choose these three
numbers I'd apply to here so you just
follow incremented by two so it doesn't
have to be something in the number line
that you do not have to think about the
continuity you can't think about the
whole space of three numbers so okay but
this is the company I mean something
like continuation of any number divided
by two
well I just look at this and say that it
conforms to the rule that I have in mind
and any would you like to try any
triples any other three numbers
and why what
cool yeah
so I'll look at this three number knees
three numbers and I say that they
conform to the rule yeah and what else
yeah so in credit s ting increments by 2
I look at these examples this example
and I say that it conforms to the rule
castles increment inc whether it
increases with Constantine
well I look at these three numbers and I
say that it conforms to the rule pilot
100 negative 10 and pie now you're doing
something like almost boundary testing
yes you can well in order to make it
much easier you can be limited to
integers but let's try this because it
ok I'll look at these numbers and I say
that they do not conform to the room and
why did you choose it whether three
random numbers
mmm is a good choice check whether
well it doesn't conform to the room so I
think something was being shaped up in
your lines would you like to try more is
there something on your mind you'll know
it I mean the subject sir 111 y-yeah to
check monotonically increasing pattern
well it does not conform to the rule
well let's say that okay let's include
all integers and so why did you try this
test for clusterf integers well this
conforms to the robe 10,000 20,000 10
million why
this conformist alittle and it's a
simple rule
just for integers and no complex numbers
yeah if you feel that you're certain
that's just that simple sorry
yeah it was a very simple rule but
almost I mean a majority of people came
up with different tree with results
which I mean the problem was I just
wanted to explain it going forward I
come up with this that one oh no I
should turned out anyway the problem is
we must all the time sit when we see 246
what comes to our mind I mean so yeah
even numbers comes to our mind when we
see that we have some hypothesis on our
minds and one of them is able numbers or
also mostly we come up with the
increasing numbers with increments of 20
or constant increments and sometimes and
it mostly people get stuck with those
and those hypotheses that they just do
not want to they just give examples
which conform to these rules such as
increments constant increments hour
increments of two even numbers in which
increments of they sometimes say that
even numbers and then they rewrote it
and say that ok I'm going to change the
reason well it starts with an even
number and it increases with increments
of two and it is the same thing as a
selling number even numbers with so
where we stuck in a space which is a
subset of the rule which is
monotonically increases increasing
numbers and it is only possible to find
out that indeed that our space of
possible instances is not limited with
the hypothesis on our 1 minus that we
initially come up with
only if by only by giving examples which
do not conform to the rule on our minds
but initially it is something very of
course first of all we give examples
which conform to our room to find out
whether our hypotheses are working or
not then afterwards we may need some
examples like this for example 5 69 is a
good example or 5 5 10 15 because we
came up probably with increments of you
and even numbers fitting increment
increases meet increments 02 and later
or what if it is not even probably so we
want to do something some kind of a
replication and we tried 1 2 1 3 5 and
later some of you said yeah well maybe
it's not by increments of two with other
constant synchronous it can be and maybe
no increments at all and whether it's
increasing or not increasing whether
it's something random so only by using
such examples we can break the circle
and we can go further and find out that
the rule is more technically increasing
numbers but it's interesting that
measure two of the people perform the
test so that their examples were they
just got stuck with answers such as even
numbers of monotony and numbers
increasing with constant increments so
it was an interesting result for us and
so I also have one test and this is the
last one so and this is called ways of
selection task and the goal is to find
out we have we are doing a statement and
this statement is where the subject is
given for cards and they are placed on a
table so the subject can only see one
side of the car and on each side on one
side of each card there is a number and
on the other side there is a letter and
we have a statement and it says that if
there is a deal on one side of the card
that because a 3 on its other side
and the goal of the subject is to find
out which cars he should turn over check
to find out whether this statement is
valid or not so what would you think
which cars you should turn over to find
out whether this food this rule is valid
or not through our photos only regarding
these now this for cool yeah why would
you like to explain reason so the
audience or is something to clear yeah
if there is a deal on the other side of
seven then this means that not every d
has a free on this other side yeah
that's the correct answer but mostly
most of the subjects prefer to check
three or just D so I indeed what we do
is something like is some simple logic
team plus Q so in order to find out p
plus q given p is correct we have to
test whether q is correct or not and
also which is equal to indeed not CLE
implies not P so even not Q is correct
which is selling in our case we have to
check whether not be is correct because
then our statements fails if not Q is
false instead of being true so
for instance while we were doing black
box testing we make I mean we as I said
before we have some test cases causes it
with the program sophistication and we
may get stuck with those but we indeed
have to efficiently cover the place the
space of possible scenarios so that we
can also cover the negative tests which
are inconsistent with the program
specifications and to find out more
defects you now find out to defects in
our code so that they cannot be or they
do not propagate to the testing phase
resins doing unit testing and this is
the similarity I mean we have to use an
effective hypothesis testing strategy to
find out the appropriate tests test
scenarios so that we can test our code
in a fact of Leon also efficiently and
here is another one and I ended it
resembles the face of selection task I
mean what is the analogy I just wanted
to give an idea but what is the analogy
between vessels will selection task and
three something let's say unit testing
or code reviews maybe I gay I took this
example from McMillian and Stacey it was
the paper that inspired me at the
beginning they were having some
brainstorming about those ideas so let's
think that we have a program and it's
always referencing a null pointer by
always checking checking before the poor
nullity before the referencing it and
someone tells you that they're actually
let's say it's a simple scenario there
are let's say in our code four sections
of the code to be tested and we have a
look at a time maybe we cannot attest
let's say for is something small but it
can be something more than that maybe I
mean the sections might be too extensive
and so we want to determine which parts
of the code needs
further investigation so we say that if
a pointer is referenced then it has to
be checked for novelty and we have
section a it checks whether the pointer
is now and the point you may or may not
have been the reference there or section
b does not check whether the pointer is
now the pointer may or may not be the
reference there and section b the
references the pointer the pointer may
or may not have been checked for nullity
and final section d where does sexually
does not Darren's the pointer and the
pointer may or may not have been checked
for nullity so which sections need
further investigation any answers yeah
could you tell us the reason for it
our daily pox I also speak yeah and then
skate yeah so first of all here if we'd
reference a pointer then we must check
whether it has been checked for nullity
or not we must control check this one
and also if it hasn't been checked for
nullity the pointer hasn't been checked
for loyalty we have to check whether it
has been dereferenced or not because if
it is if it does not check for nullity
and it was difference then this means
that we have some problems there so as a
result of our methodology we came up
with them well I'm going to sketch this
as fast as I can I know it it looks too
crowded here if you are building
predictive model so you are trying to
find so as a result we came up with this
metrics we need this metric staff and I
just I'm just going to talk about the
interpretation of these metrics a little
bit so that it can be at the same time
we perform these acts to come back with
administers these experiments this cast
on computer engineering PhD candidates
and these people have two men on two
years of experience in software
development so we also had people who
have no software development they were
just developing software for themselves
like simulators for their research and
song but we then
had a subgroup which also had they were
looking to experience and niraj was also
among them I guess who took this test
and so he had almost ten years of
development experience he performed very
well as far as I remember and so here
are the and these are about the discus
an idea about the hypothesis testing
strategy that subject / follows to find
out the correct answer in the
interactive crestline in the number
guessing game for example here I think
this come from this also conform looks
probably they look like when we plot
this is going to look like something
gradually increasing the severity of the
tests we just we have to do it like that
we have some ideas on our minds we just
check whether we just do some mild tests
to find out whether they fit or not you
just do not want to refute them
immediately but afterwards we increase
the sorority and we try examples which
refute them and afterwards we make some
practice extreme cases like a hundred
minus 10 p or ten thousand two thousand
ten million something much more extreme
than that's something like boundary
testing and then this means that at the
indeed this is the point where we are
sure or what should about what it is and
then we can try something very mild and
this is an indication that showing that
the subject is almost close F'lar
process sure about the work what correct
rules so this is an ideal pattern close
to audio pattern and this was the
pattern followed by the PhD students in
our previous university and this is
their pattern which was followed by the
developers in the gsm telecommunications
company so it is something a little bit
fluctuating and so and it's also
this fluctuation reflected the results
like how many trials they had to do
these people have to try more than once
to find the correct rope they made some
incorrect announcements and so on so on
the left side we have the written test
outcomes and this is another metric for
example and this is in psychology right
hand roots classification of verifiers
false fires and matures so if you're
very falsified you want to refute
hypothesis and if you are verified we
just want to verify I mean any I mean if
we're both being a false fire does not
mean that solely are only trying to
falsify something I mean it means that
you just want to you also include
something regarding reputation well
while you're sewing your tests and there
are measures here in our none of the
groups there are matters but measures do
not do any high any logical reasoning
they are not acting in a strategy manner
they just do things they just patch with
a match patterns like if say they have
something abstract they match the lot
numbers and letters for example in the
card case for example day CD if there's
a day on one side of the car then there
is a free on the other side they just
pick up pick up the letter D and three
and then they say that these are the
correct answers they do not logical
reasoning and sometimes did there are
some outsiders people who do not confer
do not belong to any of the previous
three categories so we came up with some
metrics we truly interpreted the results
of these metrics we observe the behavior
of the developers and also testers
analysts and then we came we want to
find out where here work we are trying
to find out we were trying hard to
quantify confirmation bias but this was
a motivation I mean does it does its
effects of your quality if it doesn't it
doesn't have effects that we
can observe then so we have to find out
the answer of this question so how the
confirmation biases of developers
effects software quality and for this
purpose we went to the field again and
we administer these tests in two
companies and there were four project
groups in the second company and in the
first company there was one project
group and the first company was an
independent software wonder and I think
it was Turkey's largest independent
software vendor and it provides ERP and
software they are specialized in
development of erp software and they
provide business solutions so the second
company is I think Europe stored largest
gsm company and telecommunications
company so they write code for the two
unknowns there advertise their campaigns
and also there is they have sinced from
the foundation of the company in 1994
they have code for building charging
Remini collection and these are the much
more mission critical software connect
compared to announcing new campaigns so
we this in the steps of our analysis we
form developer groups I mean what do you
mean my developer groups developer
groups are the people we might history
lakhs of version management systems and
we found out which groups of developers
touched the same set of files because
there are some patterns some rural
groups of developers touch the same
files over the lifetime life span of the
software and also we insulated the
installation we performed estimation of
confirmation Magpies matrix values of
developer groups so we had individual
values for the matrix but we had to map
it to the developer groups because
indeed our relation was not based on the
individual performance because anybody
can be responsible for a defect who
touches that file
I mean and it began for a specific
release any person who touches that file
before the code freeze date is
responsible because it is very possible
that that could affect my tech
propagated over the releases I might not
have been noticed so this was the
concept while we were forming our
developer groups and we estimated
developer groups confirmation bias
metrics and also do we measure to defect
rate which was for each developer group
there were certain number of files that
day means they will optum maintained and
among these number of files some of them
were defective so what was this ratio we
assimilated and we performed correlation
analysis between the developer groups
confirmation bias metrics and defect
rates well I'm not going to go deeper in
this I know there are too much number
senses a little bit but for example
let's say that in our case it didn't
happen but for example we have something
like fifty to ninety seven well in
engineering problems we have if you have
a correlation like something fifty we
said at all it's not correlated but so
when I came up with these results these
results were a little bit depressing for
me because I always look forward
correlation which is greater than 70 and
80 or and within that range then I say
that they are correlated then we came up
with the Congressional effect sizes
offered back when a psychologist and he
says that the effect sizes are I mean as
for social science just because we're
representing the ideas in terms of
constructs rather than directly
measuring them like we do in engineering
and other natural sizes so the this
wretched this limit must be lowered and
so for example if we have something
which is greater than 52 or 53 it is a
large effect it's regarded as a large
effect and so as a result of this for
example and there was no in we couldn't
observe a such case in our case but
sometimes people do not forgive some
examples they just uh no
whenever they see for example there's a
very common pattern that i came across
two while i conducted these tests two
people and it was very common they were
seeing two four six and they were trying
8 10 12 13 5 and then they were saying
announcing numbers announcing rules
series of rules without trying and you
were saying yeah well the rule is
incorrect and they were to announcing
another rule and another rule in a row
without trying anything else so it is
something related to they weren't they
had probably a list of possible
hypotheses on their mind and they were
trying to find out whether they're
correct or not without any intention of
testing it so these they didn't want to
check to validity they just wanted me to
tell them directly whether they are
correct or not so it is something which
is very highly correlated to software
defect density for instance similarly
for example Oh previously as you can for
we have very fires and their fires free
if we have the tendency to verify then
this also increases the software defect
density I mean being just only trying to
verify is not good for God so having
found out these results so we just
thought how do we just our goal was to
integrate cognitive aspects in defect
prediction models so that perhaps we can
increase the our ultimate vision was
that increase the deferred performance
of the flag prediction so our question
was how the measures of confirmation
bias performing predicting the effect on
parts of the software so we use a very
simple algorithm just because its robust
because our data as many has noise and
we also used to make a comparison we use
some conventional metrics like static
code ensure metrics and confirmation
bias matrix so we constructed models by
using any combination of the
all combinations of three different
metric types I mean only study code only
turn on the confirmation bias study
called and churn together and we know
that in the literature there are
remarkable results showing that if you
combine static code and shirin
performance increases and study code
confirmation bias going all together all
metrics what and you want to see what
the result is going to be so it is some
pre-processing and we use this
performance metrics or probably like
probably detection and probability of
detection of the and detection of the
and also the false positives the balance
and we found that well if you look well
I used minus if that matrix that doesn't
exist in building the model plus if that
metric exists in building the model and
for example when you study code in this
erp model you have something like zero
sixty-nine percent and i use only
confirmation bias we have something like
seventy four percent and let me use all
metrics i think is something due to the
correlation of the matrix anesthetic
called churn and confirmation bias
metrics that excessive amount of
correlation with themselves so it's ted
at 3474 so when we look through we
obtain comparable results if we didn't
be performed much better in some cases
we may not have not but we are results
were comparable and there is wanting
interesting about it and is that
confirmation bias is a single aspect
human aspect I mean it's not something I
mean if you say well we are going to
model human we cannot say that a human
concepts of on the confirmation bias and
probably and cognitive psychology
literature and psychology literature and
probably I am not aware of but there's
extensive amount of knowledge about
people's thought processes and they're
also work that has been going on about
personality types and basic cognitive
cognitive aspects and other confirmation
of other cognitive biases and perhaps
this may be something much close to if
we find out the appropriate
once cognitive aspects and other types
of things which can model people that we
can be much close to modeling people and
this was just a single aspect perhaps
the SID and this space is much larger
and even with a single aspect we were
able to obtain results which are
comparable with the ones such as static
code metrics and charm attics and this
means that we should go further to
investigate other human aspects so also
now we said that confirmation bias has
got to do something with it with defect
so then probably that is something
should be done to circumvent the
negative effects or confirm issue myself
confirmation bias what can be done
because in the literature dirt the
biasing techniques and there's a concept
of metacognition and the cycle and in
this field people say that and I haven't
gone through it yet but I'm really
interested in it about the concept
metacognition and this is my desire to
go further in it for different settings
since techniques for devising strategies
changes for different settings it is
said that they should be designed
individually because when you change the
settings the device and techniques does
not work efficiently effectively so it
requires a combination of psychologists
and computer scientists software
engineers to design such experiments and
to find out whether we can find
techniques to devise to fix these issues
on our lines and it's something that can
be done and it's also explained in the
book by kinda month and it's something
very easily which can be easily read
even on a bus or metro is called
thinking slow and fast and it combines
all this issues all the work that he has
done over the years with almost torski
and it was the work that he interpreted
the results for the economics field and
won the nobel prize in 2002 and he talks
about system one and system two
and so system to one of them is lazy
thanks much slower and one of them is
fast and use much more heuristics but
sometimes we have to use the wall which
is lower to tell something actually
something to the one which works faster
and by interacting these two perhaps we
can change the patterns which works much
faster and in our unconscious level and
it's possible as it is said by the
experts so that's why I wanted to find
out what factors of a confirmation bias
and this needs to be I think external
and replicated or and to find more
answers so we wanted to find out what
factors have a confirmation bias like
characteristics of the software engineer
education feel so graduate or
undergraduate degrees or the job title I
mean where it does it change whether
it's a developer tester and a little
also we included the researchers by
researchers I just mean the PhD
candidates who are actively involved in
the research projects in publications
and also at the same time these people
had as I mentioned previously so
software development experience in the
industry better as well as writing their
own code just for research purposes so I
named them under the name I could
categorize name on their name researcher
and also developing the experience does
it matter how many years we work as a
developer does it change the
confirmation bias level does make it
better or worse or testing experience
and we have some confounding factors as
a due to the nature of the data that we
collected we have some confounding
factors and they were not the main
factors due to the nature because we
didn't help from eq equal this made
fifty percent almost lost fifty percent
males or females some of the subjects
were females and majority was fear males
like most of the software development
industries and also we wanted to find
out whether about the characters scoff
company whether the company is
developing so
as a vendor or in-house saw his own
problems or it is it selling it to other
people and so we had one company from
Canada and it's a large-scale company
and they develop the database management
software so that's why it country was
also a confounding factor and we just
want to find out whether this
confounding factor affects our results
that are significant in our case because
if it is significant then there might be
something of an interaction and we
cannot trace it and we also had the
characteristics of the software product
and the development methodology some of
the inward using agile TDD and
incremental methods and so the
development languages ranges from CC
sharp show up jasp and and the level of
domain expertise change from using where
you had to some information about
Internet freedom tell communication
protocols or case bed rule-based
reasoning on the rule-based reason it
might be enough and sometimes you have
to know about the design of a database
to implement that code so it changes
sometimes you do not need to know the
cherry lying behind to implement
something but for example if you are in
the developing DBMS then you have to
know about how database is our
relational couple relational systems and
such kind of top relation calculus in so
the relational database models are
required but on the other hand when
you're doing something like a banking
software maybe you may use rule-based
case based reasoning and it might be
enough so excluding our pilot group we
had 174 subjects 18 saw researchers 100
developers and 30 analysts and 26
testers and we had for large-scale
companies and all three SMEs and one
company was in Canada remaining were in
Turkey he performed multi-way analysis
using to Stan
map lab studies tool back indeed it
looks much more like the regression
model the technicals you can integrate
as well countenance factors the
categorical factors and we want to use
as a response variable a single variable
rather than a metric set because then we
are realized that the metric site is too
crowded he is okay for predictive models
building predictive models but when you
use a single but when you use is want to
do something like a linear regression or
unaware gnosis then it gets much more
complicated so as a result of it we just
wanted to come up with a single metric
and right metric and it is something
which is the which we call the
confirmation bias level and it is the
deviation of confirmation bias metrics
values from the corresponding ideal
metrics values in terms of the LED of
distance so we have the matrix SAT for a
person and I deal values for each matrix
and thus the appearance in Oakland
distance which is mapped to the 0 1
domain so everybody had a single number
so that we could interpret the effect of
the factors on the single number and
here are some significant results and
one of the significant resources where
we couldn't find any significant effect
of education so far I mean the fields of
undergraduate or graduate study whether
it changes and interestingly we couldn't
find a significant effect of experience
in software development or testing
however we found that TDD developers
when we were hoping of other perform
better at confirmation my stance because
they most of the time they write test
before writing their own code so they
also want to find out what is what is
very might be the place where my program
may fail they already know it before
writing it up to some point and there
are also and be something wrong if there
is something before not and was
interesting that researchers performed
better than developers and what we
invent why researchers I'm going to
explain it more I mean the researchers
were not for PhD students but they were
not
they were the PhD student so computer
engineering department in Istanbul but I
mean not all of them were from the
undergraduate their undergraduate or not
was not from a large universities but
and they were from different
universities all around istanbul and
Turkey and they were admitted to do PhD
degree and they have some tongue
experience in software development and
besides that and we found out that it
provides a perquisite to do to gain some
hypothesis testing skills through some
courses like air each PhD candidate had
to take courses like all the water and
formal models from formal models and
automata theory and they have to pass a
test regarding those theory improving
and such kind of stuff throughout their
during their qualification exams because
it was a pre-requisite so I'm during day
and these people were doing research
actively they had to do it even while
they were taking courses under their
qualification exams they had to do it
and they were being followed by the
research projects so they had to they
need to have hypothesis testing skills
and perhaps it was the reason probably
it was the reason not perhaps that the
justic because they have been trained
and logical reasoning and hypothesis
testing skills they exhibit less
confirmatory behavior so some practical
outcomes well there are trainings and
companies most of the time they're
training since Java or a new software a
new tool but these trainings do not
include things about improving to
personal skills at the matter level
rather than a specific domain to improve
the skills of people regard regard at
the metal level we just give them
trainings in specific domains so perhaps
the organization's must focus on
trainings which try to email improve the
skills or people in terms of much more
abstract reasoning and as mentioned
before
perhaps we should go further and look
for things which end up such as devising
strategies maybe they should be
developed and the our goal should be to
increase metacognitive awareness among
individuals so our future direction is
towards the tool and we have been
developing to which I mentioned diode D
on a and currently we are developing the
human aspects of the tool so we have to
make things that's complicated for the
managers such as they own it so DNA is
as I said a matrix collection tool and
also it's a solve problems like
predicting to defect on parts of
software cost estimation and circuit and
we also try to find out who should form
to work together in a development team
and who's called me and must be tested
by whom and who should touch the same
files who should work as a test with it
and a sweep for example we can perhaps
use this during the recruitment of the
personal or performance emulation of the
person and it's a fact that you know
however smart we are we have these
biases and even very mmm very
intelligent people these biases are that
do exist and even people who have been
trained in logics who are expertise in
logics and magic like logic professor
status tissues they have these biases so
a multi measure to where people these
biases exist and adding the solution s
we cannot only even if you hire the
people who do not have these biases is
it wouldn't be enough for you so we have
to train these people and maybe
performance there monitor their
performance throughout the trainings and
these are all related publications so
what we are looking for we are looking
for as data science laboratory for
collaborations to work in projects to
form like new research questions to
undersell patterns in software
development in real-life settings and to
replicate the learnings in public data
sets and we just want to publish jointly
and I'd like to thank you for your time
testing if the confirmation bias
basically affecting the software quality
why don't you test the other vectors
they came at you want they go to say one
German and so are they could say the
experience is something like that might
be more of a factor then the
confirmation bias itself to determine to
something uh-huh and you said just
because confirmation bias is a construct
perhaps it's much easier to model
experience and just lots of other things
and I don't think if you should test the
more basic factors the more basic human
aspects that demo basic human actors I'm
not sure what that one yeah it's a good
question it's something I perhaps they
should it should be done and perhaps
much more basic cognitive skills can be
tested I don't know right now maybe
short-term memory and such kind of stuff
something much more basic well we just
so but first of all we just we were just
passionate about confirmation bias and
we just wanted to find it perhaps it
would be possible to find the components
at the basic level perhaps the at the
cognitive level there are basic
cognitive aspects and combinations of
these cognitive aspects might lead to
confirmation bias so there might be a
way to model the to model these
confirmation bias in terms of these
cognitive aspects and well I could I
didn't try it further but it's something
that I would be interested in service or
as a further project because if I'm
going to discover about other biases and
I'm aware of the fact that they are
combinations of some other basic
cognitive aspects so we make we must go
one level down and we must investigate
them and perhaps afterwards may go up
we could on it's all very significant we
would have change on the contrary
experience had no impact for instance so
there are also it's again part of
devices all of us have you said I highly
recommend that hospital and eventually
your whole perspective to life three
with changes and so we all make certain
assumptions they think that oh if I give
this job to X person is the person who
will do it and it turns out that he or
she may not be right about acting job
but the manager had
because he or she thinks I this person
the most experienced so this is
unavoidable and this is life but the
implications of these again when we
conducted thesis and present exact
results to each of these companies there
are some concerns people say that or
what are we going to do right now the
majority of people have invited are you
going to fire disclose the result
majority in the population all of us are
like this that are very very few people
and we have lowered eyes and what is the
likelihood of those people working your
company so that's not the idea they are
here is that you know create certain
activities instead of having the guy
being I phase of testing to spare one
day that they can spend three extra
things to improve these so there are
ways you can use devising strategies and
why you know jet pilots don't fly every
day and it's the similar thing so just
take the personality everything because
if you think that this is an important
thing that the important skill people
must have in this domain then you know
you can do certain things you can
we're a measure of the progress so today
you measure the confirmation bias there
were two years later measuring and see
what the progress has and come up with
training to improve the situation
training our Special
you should talk today has shown me
something very settled I didn't know it
explains why it's hard to explain days
because the key invades their people who
stumble over the common denominator is
device so you got me stuck in trying to
get a little reason better but they
can't reason that with the toll because
the bias is keeping it from understands
so am I going to get past that I don't
know other than I think once they get
exposed to difference in their thinking
very simple example
what was the runner it was a very very
low probability that is hit buildings
that's that but after the second attack
was ninety-eight percent gym so
everybody that's available Tobias yeah
so when you go through that personal
good person with her children met Matt
we wouldn't show them how to compute the
probability of the other and there you
have to get used to knowing more than
what I thought they're the most
important thing they have to understand
that being right more often they
understand how wrong that's a bit
confirmation bias does not do that
protects us would be psychologically it
can break past that say wait it's really
critical that I understand the odds of
being wrong because that will improve
they ought to be right that student is
almost like reconfiguration bites on his
head and you that intelligently uses to
help even though it was designed by
ability to predict yeah I don't know is
he'll just preventable as if it's a
complicated way more complicated because
we're trying to apply the engineering or
you're talking about
do you find the differences that can try
to if you
two minutes to do it versus 10 minutes
but if they think they're being brushed
great a little on purpose we didn't do
the entire intrusion well indeed when
while I was I experienced some stuff
we're always doing pilot tests I mean
yeah we didn't because according to the
protocol of the classical test there
wasn't an all time pressure we can't run
however monkey one but for example in
our PhD candidates are a little bit
competitive people and so they just
wanted to do it much much shorter and
shorter times and the record was two
minutes by one person so everybody was
asking the ricoh at the time the minimum
time before starting the test or after
the test what is the minimum time and to
discover tests we discovered it in
minimum time so and yeah they tried much
effective instances but I do not know
whether the effect was a time constraint
because it was only one group I'm going
to do it all directions I did three days
in a row fortis old people and then the
Turkish company few sets of people as
well it's although we say that it's
there is no time pressure they feel and
they they want to they probably they
feel like if it takes too long it's
embarrassing and they want to perform
here so our average was between 15-20
minutes or something like that and
although we didn't give the time
pressure we had an internal protocol if
the person couldn't finish in 45 minutes
we politely you know help the person to
announce the rule but then we
disregarded that this and there were
only a few case for 25 minutes 16
minutes come some of them
sorry yeah good question where got in
that data fit we didn't have severity
information we just had the defect
information it may have the information
and that's a good thing to learn it will
build it and actually in our last paper
lastly last work and the defect rates
and we manually because the data set was
not suitable date we mainly looked at
the the trance of whether the same
people or a few key people were grouped
together and they were causing defects
constantly and the answer was yes but we
don't know the definitive information